from the Minnesota headwaters to the
Gulf of Mexico the ground runs with
water a long grip of winter is broken
the North far north of here a colder
slower spring comes to the northern
wilderness to the source of the river
lake itasca and here with a Minnesota
spring a story begins which traces the
mighty course of the Mississippi itself
but it begins here where the river
begins with a mailbox on a lonely North
Country Road and a farm boy who had
faith in winds and river currents and
something more faith in people along the
Mississippi
he'd wanted to go down the big river
himself but instead all through the long
winter evenings it carved a small boat
deidre our ft7 task minnesota i christen
thee of mississippi
away went his fragile little boat and
with it his big winter dreams do you
think it'll make it
yes his brother hands will people be too
busy to bother with it few people will
see it at first deer or beaver may noted
silent passage through their forest or
perhaps a turtle then through desolate
cut over timberlands and then miles down
the river through rabbits
a long way to go twisting and turning
then flowing south south down the Great
River Valley the American heartland
2,400 wandering miles to go before it
reaches the river's end and waiting
hands at the Gulf of Mexico
well it might art couldn't not in a
thousand years it could you mean if
you're up where the Mississippi begins
and it's in something down it get all
the way here to the Gulf it might to
but now it rests in a Minnesota thicket
who knows who might help it on its way
[Music]
any cup there's a
[Music]
you're dead hey hey we win we win
audience Burleson your grandmother's car
Wow Wow
dear Robert Biegler I was headed home
across the shallow spot River what had
happened there was the Mississippi it
had been floating all the time we were
playing cowboys and Indians of course
none of us a real Cowboys around here
but were real honest-to-goodness Indians
chip away like my grandmother now she
speaks only chip away and she wishes I
spoke at Morton to do
she calls me Nicoya say which means he
walks in the noon but I have an American
name too in a bicycle just like other
kids I'd be playing baseball right now
except that take my father's lunch to
him he's a lumberjack drives a tractor
in the timber
[Applause]
Saturday afternoons our day to go to
town I guess it's the same with you
Robert
anyway outside one of the stores on Main
Street we got an idea we are we are we
oh yeah well Robert we added something
new to your boat Turnham fold the guided
safely on its way and so bobbing its
thanks upon every wave the Mississippi
leaves its chip away friends and after
days or weeks leaves the North Country
wilderness now strange new sights
power lines and tall bridges spanning
the river industries making important
noises along the bank
browning down upon our tiny craft the
bustling cities crowing brainerd little
pause and at last the first River Giants
Minneapolis and st. Paul
dear Robert Pedro yes where your little
boat is now it's sailing in a river
that's busy with tow boats and barges
and great dredges to dig away year after
year
keeping the channel open for navigation
this is the river I know for I am a
river cap and here's how I first saw
your little boat the Mississippi hey
look at that
they had found it Robert just about the
time my tow boat was ready to show off
downriver my daughter Tina and her
friend bill had come down to see me off
oh hi Kathy I said goodbye to them but
although I didn't know it then I didn't
say goodbye to your vote for Tina and
Bill had a plan
[Applause]
[Music]
alright Castille
[Music]
well Robert that's how your vessel got
tied on mine anyway you're welcome to
tag along with us down to st. Louis down
one of the richest river valleys in the
world you're going down with a freight
train of the river a tow boat besides
your little boat we are navigating a
string of oil barges wider and longer
than the Queen Mary
our first stop by the way will be La
Crosse Wisconsin one of our crew members
Pete Shaw is getting married there Pete
claims he's not nervous but I've got an
idea he's doing a pretty good job of
covering up here's the lock where Pete
gets off Pete comes from Arkansas he's a
long way from home
Pete told me about the wedding
afterwards how everything Karen pointed
out to him seemed strange the rolling
countryside the way they farm and the
names of the people whose farms they
passed slants and Burkes them in
Hollywood Karen never guessed it but the
site the Wisconsin dairy farm may Pete
long to see cotton growing in Arkansas
and then Karen's home Pete felt like a
stranger and wondered what was in store
for him there hadn't been many people at
the wedding he told me yes he figured
people just weren't very friendly in
that part of the country but then all of
a sudden our wrong can you defeat one
the people whose names were purchased
from an armed Christmas fences in fact
all the neighbors from miles around gave
them a real old-fashioned welcome Pete
found out that people in Wisconsin
aren't too much different from those in
Arkansas
but later that night somewhere down the
river from the cross there was a
floating uprooted tree and the line to
your boat snapped tallest and then
another tow boast looming out to the
darkness and that Robert was the last we
saw of your little boat hey what's that
out there hey fellas look at this T
Robert B grrah I found the Mississippi
in our gang Swimming Hall
it was pretty banged up so I decided to
take it home with me your name's Fred
Robert and mine's German Hans Kruger I
live on a farm new Guttenberg Iowa most
of the people in this part of the
country came from Germany a long time
ago
chairman stonemasons built his church we
go to it's about a hundred years old and
you ought to see the riverfront Street
and Guttenberg
my great grandmother says it looks just
like a little German town but you can't
prove it by me the country near the
river is one hill after another but it's
some of the best farming land in Iowa
that's something I do know about I just
got home in time that day I found your
boat it was Saturday and just about
every Saturday our family goes to the
build my mother was going shopping but
my dad and I we were gonna sell Frieda
Frieda the heifer you see
and heifers a young cow that hadn't had
a calf yet anyway
Frieda was on her way to the Dubuque
auction buyer - all bye bye bye to find
out haven't gonna get that bottle family
that's a delicate get some family does
everything all I can to get seventy but
again I've gotta get to my after that
might that's a bike yeah I have five and
eighty me four dollars gonna get Dan oh
alright boys we got a good oversteer
here nowhere do you understand him that
Bob what's the money on them good load
of her purse here Freddie
her hands what you got oboz not much of
a boat not worth trading for anything
that's all you know came all the way
down from the beginning of the
Mississippi River almost a thousand
miles it did
let's see yeah let's see it yeah let's
see it
boy look at them know how long it's
taken to get you can't I'll trade you my
pocketknife for it huh okay I'll throw
in this that's a neat compass shared
hands hey why not put it on the boat you
mean put my stoppers on your boat
sure boat needs compass doesn't it gee
Terry if you put it on it'll sort of II
you're both too and we'll help it go in
the right direction experiment so what
all right let's go get it fixed up well
that's how it was Robert y'all went over
to the Dubuque shipyard where they build
big river barges and cobalt
[Applause]
go to the yard hey why do you kids think
you're gone boy were we scared
I told him about your vote we'll just
put a compass on we wanted to launch it
okay fellas go ahead
hey thanks mister yeah thanks I wonder
where to go now
it has come from the Minnesota
headwaters to st. Paul from Saint Paul
to La Crosse Wisconsin River City from
the cross to Dubuque on Iowa shores and
at last st. Louis largest river city of
them all nerve center of the modern
river but city of century-old levees
here the Mississippi pauses but not for
long a little girl whose
great-grandparents journeyed overland in
a covered wagon ties a toy packet in tow
a dime store reminder of the river Tom
Sawyer knew now from st. Louis on down
the levied river of small southern towns
of cotton scorching Summer Sun of yearly
flood hey what's that down there dear
Robert Biegler that was the first time
my friend Paul and I saw your boat we
tried to get it but the levee dropped
off too steep and the tide was taking it
away the river was pretty high for that
time of the year there were flood
warnings out crest was supposed to reach
our Tyler next day we watched it till
disappeared the Lynn said goodbye to
each other
Paul I might always been good friends
ever since we were real young but lately
we hadn't been seeing too much of each
other just happened to meet on the levee
that day today the flood took your boat
away heart or keeping the waters back
sometime it comes almost up to the
street signs
but this year it wasn't too bad suffer
down by the river
harley came to the third step of my
house
lily water went down pretty quick and a
few days you'd hardly know they'd been a
flood at all I'm a statue I'm a stat -
Ravi oh mama
swing me harder than ever here come on
hammer coffee come on swing me swing me
swing me row fan my Ravi Armand you all
right there look already go with your
Hey look at me Who am I that's Bob I'm
next well gee whiz believe it or not
there was your boat again Robert I was
so surprised I ran all the way across
town to where Paul lives hey Paul where
are you hey Paul what's up come and see
what I got what is it come and see gee
whiz how did you get the boat flood wash
it right up on our front porch
let's go lodge it all oh well I'm sorry
Robbie but I'm playing a game right now
some other time
you
hey Robbie wait to me it was Paul he
come to help me after all so Robert Iger
that's why Paul and I are writing this
letter you see Robert we thought you'd
like to know how your boat sort of
brought two old friends back together
again
but there will be days when the vast
Loire River will seem without in Memphis
Vicksburg Natchez and at last with luck
New Orleans great trading and
manufacturing center river port and port
of the world freighters loading for
Brazil Java the Indies and it will be
here that our tiny craft will need all
the luck in the world
[Music]
and it's luck will hold thrown out by a
paddlewheel
[Music]
carry downriver
we're free once more get drift off
course into a mysterious land of boss
country of Cajun boys with French names
like be ashamed Ouma moving silently
through a Louisiana bayou and here to
our boat we'll need luck a little poem
what's it say in the sail down the
Mississippi
it's off-course I wonder how it channel
about Gators and it's luck we'll
continue in a lonely title be pretty
good Caspian first of all look what we
caught well he's way off course we'll
see that it gets back but on its way to
the south pass the channel to the sea it
passes a gulf shrimp fleet running the
forest storm warning a tropical perky
[Music]
[Applause]
and now it lies landlocked and lost at
lands in lost and unnoticed for days or
weeks or months but then
dear Robert Baker I just knew it could
happen
[Music]
you must have hundreds of letters by now
robbery and makes ours won't be the last
but we've painted a new message on your
cell around the world from a little boy
in Minnesota to people along the
Mississippi and here at the rivers in to
the peoples of the world now where is it
bound and who will bring it ashore
you
[Applause]